what do we want save [ __ ] when do we
want it now what do we want
[ __ ] when do we want it now
p are as welcome as pirates in dover
workers and supporters marching in
protest at the unlawful sacking of 800
seafarers backed by a community defined
by its port
among those affected rachel and
daughter's neve and hope whose father
was fired after 20 years at sea
devastating
it's not like soul destroying
and worrying about paying your mortgage
feeding your children
the votes should be seized and taken
away
well i'm telling the truth
in lan that's exactly what's happened
the european causeway deemed unfit to
sail and detained by safety inspectors
because of failures in training new crew
to replace the 45 staff sacked 10 days
ago
sous chef john joined piano straight
from school but won't risk going back on
board now and i don't think it's
realistic at all to see them back in
service anytime soon and if they are
back in service
early next week you think they'll be
safe well i wouldn't travel on them no
way no no i would not have them
they marched in liverpool too union
leaders vowing to fight on
these are highly competent people there
are skilled engineers there are
navigators this cannot be given to
people who've never even seen these
vessels many of them they've been
brought over and are going into some of
the busiest shipping lanes in the world
on a wing and a prayer frankly and that
has got to be unacceptable safety is
paramount but the safest crew is the
crew that they sacked
piano's plan was to have its fleet
including three ships on the crucial
dover calais route back at sea by now
instead it's losing one million pounds a
day and safety certification will not be
a walk over it's a serious situation um
any ship whether it's passenger ship or
a tanker or cargo ship
being detained is probably a ship
owner's worst nightmare
but it's there for a reason you can
imagine yourself the size of a one of
these vessels is like a very large
office spot so they do need a lot of um
getting used to and you can't expect a
crew to go on board
and suddenly just take over overnight
piano have been training 450 new staff
who'll be paid little more than five
pounds an hour here in dover for the
last week and i understand on monday the
maritime and coast guard agency will
conduct a safety inspection of the pride
of kent on tuesday it'll be the turn of
the pride of canterbury should they fail
piano's whole plan will be in trouble
piano says it will make changes to
return the european causeway to service
but with its fleet tied up just two
weeks before the easter holidays and its
reputation sinking this entire
enterprise may be in peril paul kell
says sky news in dover